[Music]
so here's the here's the here's the
situation so this is recording so this
is going to go live on our podcast feed
so the people listening on the podcast
there's you and then there's people who
are live right now i think over a
thousand people live so we're on this
thing called stonks.com i guess i got i
got i got to do it to close disclosure
i'm an investor sean are you an investor
no
fan
fan so stocks.com it's they uh we were
friends with them they asked us to do
this and it was actually we say no to
everything but this was a cool idea so
basically five startups are going to
pitch us and we're gonna maybe invest
but very likely tear them apart and also
complement them we're gonna make like
some good content out of this right
yeah uh yeah okay great i'm down and we
don't know
much about these startups ahead of time
so it's all gonna be kind of fresh
and there's a comment section do you see
the comments section sean like where
people are chatting yeah so like if
there's any good questions and also on
the skype they can invest right like
they can put in money
yeah so like if they see something i i
don't think they can like they're not
literally gonna fund the company right
there but they're gonna say like i'm
interested let's talk
and honestly that's probably what i'm
gonna do i'd never like on these things
i know i cannot like i've seen these
things and someone's like i'm in for a
hundred thousand dollars and they say
they're like right on the spot i'm not
that impulsive are you uh yeah i'm that
impulsive uh and it's also more dramatic
so i'm a sucker for the drama i'll do it
all right all right well at least one of
us will um and then do you if you go to
the chat of this video thing you'll see
the order of of people that they're
gonna go and um we're gonna talk to one
person i think they get two minutes and
then we get eight minutes to talk to
them and then it's gonna say like time's
up move to the next one does that make
sense this is pretty sick let's do this
all right uh we have john hancock uh
from stonks is like our assistant here
he's going to be feeding a startup so
john do you want to bring the first one
up john is that a real name
i don't think so hey guys
what's up tarus
how's it going thank you so much for the
time
okay take it away
awesome my name is darris i'm the
founder and ceo of 5x um been fortunate
enough to spend my career in the data
space from being the first data engineer
at salesforce the most recently running
data for wework supporting thousands of
employees
over the last few years been super
interested in the modern data stack it's
estimated that over 77 of companies in
the next 10 years in some way shape or
form are going to use the modern data
stack
the problem is that there's a big
disconnect in what vendors are selling
today and what customers need over 90 of
customers are investing in data to get a
business roi yet the vendors are really
focused on selling individual categories
what this means is that customers have
to have expertise they need to sign
multiple contracts they need to stitch
this together all of this is taking away
from actually getting business output
5x is the first end-to-end data platform
which is focused on business output so
we license and integrate with the
different vendors in the space and as an
end result we can provide customers with
an end-to-end platform depending on
their use cases industry size budget
on top of this we also have a services
model where we can give companies access
to high quality engineers who are
pre-trained on the stack today we
interview hundreds of engineers fully
automated and we get to hide the top 0.1
percent end result customers can
implement end-to-end data strategies in
weeks instead of spending time signing
all these contracts for less than a year
old million dollar run rate on a poc
with zero marketing
and we're super excited that we are
going to be profitable by the end of
this month
all right
uh good stuff um
sam so uh what does this business do
that's what i'm
i'm trying to i i was trying to
interrupt you earlier but i think i was
muted um i need can you kind of dumb
this down for me for a little bit i'm
looking at you so so let me for the
listeners all right so the website is 5x
dot co
right now you are raising 300 000 at a
25 million valuation you got to a
million dollars in arr in less than a
year i don't know what poc means when i
see poc at people of color that's what i
thought about that
point of contact
okay so
like uh some companies are telling you
that they're gonna pay you up to a
million dollars right or collectively or
they actually have
they actually are paying us monthly
and dude you got a million dollars at a
proof of concept that sounds pretty sick
to me okay but
i'm gonna be honest i don't know what
the hell you do
can you explain to me i've never worked
at a big company before so i'm kind of
like a big dumb idiot it's not just for
big companies think of you know if you
want to get value from data
fundamentally you need two things you
need infrastructure you need tools
infrastructure you might have heard of
tableau or snowflake and the second
thing you need is people now the way the
infrastructure is working today is every
vendor is really focused on one small
part of the stack so if you want to do
something like analytics you need to go
sign four or five different vendors sign
these upfront contracts and stitch this
together yourself now if an industry is
going to become mainstream
then you can't really expect ninety
percent of customers who don't know
when you say words like vendors it's
it's still hard for me understand give
me a very specific example you used
network format
yeah you use the format that's like um
x x company had y problem
yeah they tried z
but the problem with z is this so then
we came in and we do it differently
instead
sure so x company you know wants to
figure out whether the customer name
name
yeah name
sorry that was actually used one of our
customers bank novo wants to figure out
where the customers are coming from how
do they personalize the app how do they
save costs and you know optimize this
sort of cash flow
they
now
don't know where to go they can go buy a
single reporting tool like tableau but
the end-to-end data strategy is a lot
more comprehensive there's a lot more
than just having a dashboarding tool
instead of having to hire multiple
engineers instead of having to go sign
all of these different tools and vendors
they come to 5x 5x instantly gives them
an end-to-end platform which has got all
of these vendors we license these
vendors and can give customers an
end-to-end platform
on top of this if bank if bank nova
doesn't have the resources to figure out
how to go use it they can add uh
engineers on our site who are
pre-trained on the platform end result
they're getting business output in weeks
whereas if they tried to go do this
themselves it would be 12 times slower
and six times more expensive
all right that's way better um and one
question how on earth did you get people
to spend a million dollars with you on a
proof of concept because this sounds
like a very hard thing to sell and a
million dollars is a lot of money on and
is it actually like they're gonna pay
you a certain amount of money every
single year
yeah so you know at the moment you know
we so in the next two months
our self-service platform will be live
right so anyone will be able to go to 5x
enter the credit card for a few hundred
bucks a month you'll have
the you'll have the you'll have the
platform so early stage companies can do
this by spending very little money what
we do today because the self-service
platform isn't ready we combine the a
semi-automated platform plus a services
model so you get engineers plus you get
uh
plus you get the platform so our average
order value at this point is about 10k a
month um
multiply that by about 10 15 customers
we're at a million dollar plus fund rate
which basically means you're doing it by
hand from now and then you're uh raising
money so you can automate it all
correct it's semi-automated already it
would take a consultant about three or
four months just to give you that
platform they would go build it and they
would start from scratch we do it in
less than one day today
that's pretty semi-automated and where
are these customers coming from so let's
dig into this 1 million of ar so you
said you got 10k per customer roughly 10
15k
um and
roughly 10 customers that are paying you
monthly right now
um so you got 100k a month uh you know
roughly roughly in revenue
where did these customers come from is
this inbound outbound do you have a
growth strategy like do you have a
strategy that would just lead you to the
next 3 million also sure at the moment
we've done zero marketing we've been
really been focused on on the platform
we have been producing content on my
linkedin um on youtube
mainly getting customers by word of
mouth and by that so really the last
eight months were early on
using this to the proof of contra uh
using this as a proof of concept this is
not just a technology problem you have
to convince all of the vendors in the
space to give you api access to
provision them integrate with them build
for them um so you know you need it's a
little bit of a chicken and an egg
problem where you need customers and at
the same time you need to show these
vendors that you that you they actually
is traction and we become an added sales
channel for them
huh okay
i uh what else sean
uh i guess i'll just give you a little
bit of feedback on the pitch itself so
um
a couple things
your house or wherever you're at super
nice um almost distractingly nice i kind
of like my founders to be a little more
uh scrappy than that just gonna put that
out there where are you
i'm in bali
oh he's in bali man it's probably it's
probably
not the most uh expensive place yeah
yeah fair enough uh second thing um you
know i think you wanna i think you tried
to get the most information into the
pitch whereas i think you kind of want
to slow down and you need to just like
work on that first 30 seconds to
figure out the thing that i was confused
about samus confused about most of the
chat if you look on stonks was confused
about which was i don't really know what
this does right when you say end to end
that makes sense to you because you're
knee-deep in it but for us we've never
heard of 5x before so we're like end to
end what and yeah you know all of the
all of the words were quite um
you know generic so like you know
vendors blah blah
and uh and so you what you want to do is
basically just be able to
to paint a picture so you know
did you ever work at a company that had
this problem or if you've ever been the
marketing manager to company you know
that you spend almost you know six
months getting your analytics platform
and then integrating it and then you
have to get your crm and then integrate
it then you have to do this and then
integrate it and so it takes months just
to get set up with the things you need
to be able to see your business and
every business has the same problem so
what we do is we go to that person and
we say hey use us and you get xyz right
benefits out of this and people are
choosing it because of this we got a
million dollars in uh an ar already as a
you know during our pilot just you know
in a couple weeks or whatever it is now
i'm kind of more engaged
what else here and look this is actually
quite easy what year did you join wework
someone in the chat said this guy made a
bunch of money off the wework ipo and
then i just went to your website and it
said you worked at wework so i don't
know what the truth is i joined in i
think
or 2017. uh i did not make money off the
ipo that's okay that's irrelevant i i
mean that would have been sick if you
were it looks like you did because
you're in that nice house but um i guess
what i was trying to get at is
i would do exactly what sean said but i
would use the wework story so we were at
when i when i worked at we were because
you were the head of data it looked like
at wework or something like like some
like pretty
you led data for wework your bio says
that sounds impressive it doesn't matter
if it is but it sounds like it and so i
would use the story of like i led data
at wework when we were this size and i
grew the company to this size and a
problem that we consistently had was
blank blank blank
and we solved it by hiring tons of
people and it was still like riddled
with heirs and and talking to other
people in this data world i noticed they
all had the same problem and so to
bootstrap this company and get it off
the ground i hired a couple friends and
we actually have been doing this by hand
and we convinced x y and z to give us
some money and slowly or
quickly we've actually automated a lot
of it um and we've automated by doing x
y and z so now all these companies who
want to get this thing done they can
actually use us and instead of hiring 30
people they just use have one person use
this bit of software and it saves them x
amount of money in x amount of time you
know what i mean
like i have by the way i'm just totally
written i don't know any of this is true
no that was great but you know what i
mean
yeah totally
um but now if we should just get to the
product i think it sounds neat and it
looks like my good friend ankur invested
and he's actually quite um
he's actually quite impressive as he
knows his [__] i think it's a cool
company yeah i would i would definitely
just based off your traction alone i
would want to learn more because
okay uh you know a good pitch is not
necessarily a good business but good
traction is usually a good business and
so you actually have good traction at a
bad pitch that's okay
so i would want to learn more and uh and
dig in to understand how much of this is
a service and consulting business versus
is this going to be software and this is
going to be automated because it sounds
like you've actually found a problem
that people care about um we'll see how
how kind of durable that is and then we
can go from there so
um thanks for coming on man i think you
know for both of us it seems like the
answer is like we'd actually want to
learn a little bit more
and look at the deck before we uh we go
too far
amazing thank you thank you you're
awesome
thanks for uh bringing brave and doing
this
so sean he um
so on this stocks platform it says he's
got 75 000 of interest i do agree this
potentially is more of a services play
um but we actually just talked about
that company worldwide technology and
this sounds just like it doesn't it
yeah there's there's several companies
that are like this uh there's a lot of a
lot of sas companies that have like a
like either
a consulting thing that's how they get
it embedded or it's like just an ongoing
revenue stream and it actually can get
quite substantial so i don't think
that's a complete um no i didn't i
didn't think about that i didn't mean
that as a disc i kind of said it as like
uh is this just this consulting company
because if it was just a consulting
company i would not do it but um
but yeah i i was just so confused for
half the time i didn't really get to
think about uh didn't really get to
think about the business to be honest i
was trying to figure out what that does
yeah that was a little bit of an error
hopefully he'll fix that but uh this
type of business i think it'd be sick to
own i don't know if you if i don't know
why you'd want to raise money if you got
a million dollars in
just selling by the way the simple test
here is uh like just say the first like
30 to 60 seconds of your pitch to
somebody
and then be like uh to a friend and just
be like um hey can you play that back to
me like so based on what i said what
does my company do like and what you
want to know is do they get it first of
all like you have to get it and then are
you interested in it does it sound
compelling and if it's like if you don't
get it it's not compelling like don't
move forward don't go to the rest of the
pitch and you need a friend or you need
like random people who are going to do
that and the format you use was good
because you you sort of like added the
team and credibility well when i was
leaving data for wework right you know
uh all the shenanigans were going on but
in my little corner of the world we
actually had this much you know this big
problem that we had to deal with
and uh that's where i kind of realized
that
every company has this issue that they
can blank blank and it's like oh yeah
that's a good format generically for a
pitch yeah i agree um all right uh john
hancock you want to send us the next one
all right all right kenny you got it
hey guys thanks for having me on the
show so i am kenny i'm one of the
co-founders of baccarat and we've built
the world's first online marketplace for
group airfare and the problem that we
set out to solve is that group airfare
flights of 10 or more people traveling
to together it's sold offline so what
does this mean say that you are a uh
you're organizing an 8th grade school
trip and you're flying 50 people from
san francisco to orlando if you want to
shop for uh for quotes you actually have
to call the air call the airlines group
desk over the phone and once you get
something that you like well the offline
nature of groups doesn't end there it's
really important to note that group
airfare is unlike booking a normal
ticket so it actually takes place in
five unique stages and that's from
shopping to deposit to final payments
and make names list and before baccarat
all of that happened over the phone so
we thought in 2022 this is insane that a
world with so much money in it uh
operates totally offline so we created
what's like a b2b expedia-like
marketplace for shopping for flights of
10 or more people
in terms of traction
we
we did launch baccarat
in
october of 2021
we have really strong growth great unit
economics and we're actually profitable
um as a business model we make between
10 and 15 margin on flights and from
january to april we've done 4.2 million
dollars worth of total sales
we take about 1700 in revenue per per
group and have 40 corporate customers
that are using the platform today
and one of the most exciting things that
happened
as a result of the pandemic is we got a
ton of inbound from corporate meeting
and team off sites that are looking to
book group airfare it's our fastest
growing customer segment and it's caused
us to build out a bunch of tools to meet
the needs of meeting planners
and you're probably asking
why is uh why is this the team to bring
group airfare from analog to digital
well we have really deep uh domain
expertise in group travel our ceo eric
previously sold a tour operator business
where he kind of learned the ropes of
the business and then our team
internally from the service side to the
tech side we have a lot of deep
expertise in travel tech and we think
that we have a shot to be both the
storefront and the underlying operating
system for group airfare so we'd love to
answer any questions that you have about
our business
are we live or
can you hear us dude the top comment is
actually pretty funny which it says fly
together
and brewflights.com
is available uh
go buy the domain yeah go buy the domain
yeah get on that one
you got the uh the stocks chat adding
value here they're the real value-add
investor i love this
also i like how you just like looked
downstairs like ma go buy the domain
wow the meatloaf
yeah
i thought you were like a chinese
gambling website when you uh when you
first came on i thought this is baccarat
well based on your last podcast that
wouldn't be a bad idea too
this is crazy
fair enough
let me ask a clarifying question on the
pitch you said that you get 10 to 15
percent and i think your chart said did
your chart say a hundred thousand a
month in bookings or did it well your i
forget what you but you you said four
million
did you believe attraction slide again
yeah it was like four million between
january and april does that mean that
between january
january and april you did four million
but then
yeah so we gmv correct we did yeah
exactly so we've sold 4.2 million
dollars worth of group airfare and we're
averaging about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a month in revenue and
that's the revenue that like it's real
revenue
and how old's the business
so we started in 2018 uh we survived the
pandemic just barely um and then
probably like half of our clients kind
of uh didn't make the pandemic so it's
kind of like a fresh restart for us um
prior to us launching flight shopping we
were just a trip management platform for
tour operators so like if someone did
like a lot of student travel sending
people to like dc and orlando they would
use our trip management platform just a
way to stay organized and make sure that
they don't miss deposits and final
balances uh and then we had a lot of
time to ourselves during the pandemic so
we made flight shopping because it was
our number one request people don't want
to call the airlines for quotes and then
how many people work there
we have 11 now cool got it okay
okay um so maybe in each of these sam
when we do like uh first i kind of like
clarifying questions slash like reaction
to the business and then maybe some
pitch feedback at the end of like how to
get that better but like okay so
reactions to the business and clarifying
questions
so um
you are trying to do group travel uh for
corporate
and um
and you said something at the beginning
which was like it's insane that there
isn't really a good solution for
something with this much money in it i
didn't catch did you say how much is
spent booking group travel every year
yeah so i didn't it's about 130 billion
dollars worth of just total group spend
um and that equates to about five
percent of an error line's revenue so
floating around about
225 million passengers fly as part of a
group um pre-pandemic
okay cool so five percent of airline rev
airline revenue is done via these groups
and that's all kind of the over the
phone or something like some other
old-school method at the current
currently
exactly yep
okay cool and then what's the why now
because people have been doing like
travel startups
forever uh like you know
booking.com priceline these were i think
booking.com person came out like in 1995
or something crazy like that yeah and so
why has nobody tackled this part of it
because i've seen
travel startups in every angle
but what is there anything that's
unlocked now or you're just you finally
have a great idea what's going on here
no so not finally have the great idea uh
we do have some people that are
competitors that sell a sas solution to
airlines that allow airlines to make
like a white label version of what of
what what we do the why now is before
the pandemic lufthansa american airline
united is rumored to be working on it
they want to go digital for their groups
and they've actually instituted a
private white label and so we see it
happening in the same way that like
single tickets came online we think
groups will come online so the airlines
are already starting to do the
underlying tech and we think that's
amazing and we want to be basically that
that second shelf that they sell their
their their group airfare in
how are you getting the customers now
because isn't travel like the hardest
like uh when i think of like hardcore
customer acquisition people i think of
like online gambling i think of gaming
and then like travel
yeah like that seems like the most cut
one of the most cutthroat industries to
get customers because i think um the
guys who started reddit started hit monk
and uh it didn't work out because they
just like couldn't get like or you know
it wasn't as big nearly as big as reddit
uh
how are you getting those customers yeah
so currently right now about 99 of our
business is b2b so we get customers
really in two core ways uh one we have a
referral pro of referral program so we
are a
we're a preferred partner for like
meeting planners and tour operators in
the student travel space and if you
refer us business we give you like five
dollars per uh per per ticket book that
has been enough to send us so much
business that we have to like hire and
raise money uh then the second way is
kind of old school like industry events
are still really popular just meeting
with meeting planners and tour operators
uh and then something that we'll try to
get better with um in time is like seo
there's not a lot of of competition for
like the keywords group airfare before
the pandemic we got it down to like 72
cents a click um but admittedly since we
just survived and we didn't have the
capital to run a bunch of marketing
experiments uh we're not doing any paid
at the moment
and then until now you get a bunch of
savages in the chat that are all going
to start beating you up
they already bought the domain fly
together before you can get it so
explain what are the terms of the raise
so you're raising how much at what
valuation yeah so we would like to raise
1.5 million dollars at a 15 million cap
great and so for somebody listen to the
podcast there's people who listen to
podcasts that don't uh they're not part
of like the angel investing scene
how does a couple
are you just 15 million dollars wait but
you said you're doing 150 000 a month in
revenue so is it some revenue multiple
just explain where's this 15 million
magic number come from for you yeah so
um we have our customers book pretty far
out so like our average customer books
nine nine months out so through the end
of the year we should make about 1.5 1.6
million dollars in revenue and so we
just took that top line number and times
it by 10 to kind of be safe no there's
been crazy stuff happening but we want
to be set up for success and fair
so we just times it by 10. and then what
is the like what's actually happening
under the hood so you didn't show like a
demo or search engine or how somebody
actually does this
is there are there apis are you just
like calling the airline yourself under
the hood like what's what's actually
happening yeah so under the hood we are
connected with two are you familiar with
like travel technology
no okay so really high level i know that
where time is running out so we're
connected to two gds's called saber and
amadeus that's how we get the flight
content and then we had to build some
stuff on top to make sure that groups
work because there's limitations of the
legacy system but i think our time is up
and that could be a whole podcast let me
ask one let me ask one more question um
this is something that i love asking
everyone that i invest in which is like
5 10 15 years down the line how does
this how big how much revenue are you
gonna be making and how am i gonna get
my money back
yeah i think that we can be both the
store the the store front and the
underlying pipes for groups so uh if you
were thinking about getting like a ride
you would open the
uber app if you were thinking about
booking flights of 10 or more i think
that you come to back right.com but how
do i and so how big do you think the
business will get and what's gonna
happen someone's gonna buy you for a
billion dollars someone's gonna buy you
100 million dollars you're going to go
public what do you think will happen
yeah
there's a there's a really uh a really
clear path for us that we get to like 50
million dollars in revenue in the next
like five to six years um and beyond
that i'm not totally sure but i the path
to 50 is pretty clear that's a good
answer okay yeah that's a great answer
uh in general fantastic pitch actually
uh
the thing i was saying before gotta be
clear gotta be compelling in the first
minute you were extremely clear
extremely compelling i think it's pretty
pretty clear you know your stuff uh as
you were asked questions about it you
had good honest answers you didn't
oversell but you um you got to the point
on on each one of those questions so i
think a really strong really strong
pitch as far as i'm concerned
yeah i would i i i'd love to learn more
cool
awesome
that was a good one
it was very it was very very very very
clear one thing that wasn't clear which
is like uh how big is this pro i mean i
don't know anything about group flights
and it turns out
so he said it's like it it's a hundred
billion dollars worth of tickets booked
a year as group flight is that what he
said
130 billion of group spend which is five
percent of all airline revenues what he
said yeah he buried the lead on that one
a little bit yeah exactly so like you
know that question we asked that's got
to go to the front of his presentation
which is like
um
yeah booking group travel sucks and by
the way this sounds like it might just
be this fringe thing but there's over
130 billion a year going through uh
group group travel and today that's all
done still on the phone which is crazy
because most of all other ticketing 98
other 80 of the other ticketing is just
done online now yeah that's going to
happen for group travel and we're going
to make it happen right i would have
been like
all right so group travel is defined as
10 or more tickets guess how much
revenue is booked per year doing that
yeah guess how much revenue is a nice
one a confidence b makes the other
person insecure c they're almost always
going to guess wrong when you have a
really high number because they just
don't have right the right framework you
say 128 billion that's 5 of all tickets
are booked that way and guess how they
book it
they have to call the airline and book
it all like manually it's a pain in the
butt like that's how i would have done
it but he did he did really good and i
would put a screenshot of the website be
like this is a you know if i go to like
whatever delta or i go to expedia like
look all the there's a million buttons
on the screen there's not one if you
want to find the group button go to help
go to phone
this is where you go for that this is
where 130 billion flows through right
like i really emphasize that problem and
then i'd show my screen which is like a
google search engine that's like here's
how it works on fly together you just go
here you just say how many people where
you're going and then we take care of
the rest we do a bunch of crazy stuff
under the hood to make that automated um
and it's working we have you know we've
done 4 million in bookings so far
that translated into 150 000 a month of
revenue for us so we're on a x mil you
know 2 million run rate
and uh by the end of the year blah blah
blah dude
i agree everything said one thing that
what it bothered there's two things that
when startups when i'm talking to them
that bothers me one is when they use arr
and it's not actually annually recurring
revenue and they're like well it means
um at annual run rate i'm like dog come
on you know like none of us like use
that word that way and the second thing
is when they say revenue but it's gmv
which stands for i don't gross
merchandise volume so it's like if
you're ebay you sell
technically like let's say a hundred
billion worth of stuff but ebay only
captures five percent of that you know
i'm making that up but like i i need
it's so confusing to me when they say
that i wrote this note during the thing
right like i have this little white
board here i'm writing on i wrote
revenue presented weirdly because he
wrote 4.2 million in sales but it was
like that's an aggregate over five
months then he wrote like uh
we take 1.7 per customer it's like dude
just say how much revenue you have like
make that the first one we do this much
per month per year that's our current
run rate
that's that's not gmv that's what we
take home
in terms of gmv we've done this much
right like that would be a big
improvement over uh
over the attraction side but very very
cool company though you want to do
another one mr hancock where yeah
hello what's
up all good
and uh thanks for doing that it's
actually really fascinating
so my name is oren i'm the co-founder
and ceo of munch and i'm accompanied by
peter my co-founder and cto and we both
have
i have too many years of experience in
business and tech leadership growers and
we've been building much for the past
few months
getting out of the validation phase and
into our mvp and initial attraction
so what is munch think about your
favorite youtuber apart from results
let's say this person has 1 million
subscribers on youtube
now what if i tell you that chances are
that this person has almost all
of other content professionals has only
one to two successful distribution
platforms
i mean this is mostly the case in in
almost all cases this is because it
takes a lot of time money professional
know-how to succeed on each and every
social platform it's actually pretty
different to be successful on tiktok or
facebook or instagram or youtube
totally different platforms and
different audiences
due to that most of them don't even try
to
to put it in that effort and kind of
give up even though it can grow their
revenue streams and their monetization
potential quite
quite in quite a reasonable
numbers
so
we are a team of builders dreamers and
coding curators on a mission to build
the first platform that we serve as a
home for content creating professionals
there are no
other platforms currently serving as a
home as a place that the current
profession can do everything
from
creating their
their new content based on data driven
processes repurposing the content for
different types of platforms doing
research on what's the next
next content that they want to create
and actually distribute it on all
platforms and monetize
the content creation market is currently
estimated at around 65 billion dollars
with an annual growth rate of 15
this means that it will get to 140
billion dollars by 2026
and combine that with the creator
economy we're talking about 200 billion
dollars market it's a rather big market
and we are currently raising five
hundred thousand dollars on top of the
nine hundred thousand dollars that we
already raised we have 250 000 already
committed and we're looking for 250 more
the idea is to take this money and use
it to boost our dev team and create the
first version of the product by this
november
increase of traction and start and
start testing different pricing levels
with their initial paying
customers so we're looking for some new
partners that can actually
teach us a bit more about the media
business
okay first of all let me say the people
who are not english speaking and pitch
[__] awesome that would i cannot
imagine how hard that it's not easy it's
not easy i could tell it wasn't easy it
you did pretty good but uh golly that
seems like a rough thing to have to
learn how to do congratulations
we can barely speak when it's our native
language so you know uh respect for that
um
okay
now i could be mean
that was a horrible pitch though uh i
respect the attempt but the actual
structure of the pitch
um
was just not great and uh like you know
in the chat here on stonks on a scale of
one to ten ten being that was super
clear and compelling one being i was
cloudy and not compelling give it a
score one to ten i'm curious what it was
for for you guys one being low not
clearing compelling ten being very very
clear and compelling type it in the chat
and they're on like a way they're on
like a 15 second delay by the way
so i'm saying
an eight and then two two three two one
three one two one two one one one right
okay so your job orin is
to get that two
into an eight right because like right
now i can barely even give you kind of
feedback on the business itself like i
went to your website so i went to
getmunch.com and it looks like basically
what you're doing is a creator spends a
ton of time let's say making a video or
a long form post they're kind of drained
by the end of that
and um and so they post it on the one
platform they post on youtube you take
that content you turn it into clips you
put it on tiktok you take that content
you turn it into tweets you you
basically repurpose the conte chop it up
and repurpose it so they can get more
juice out of the content they made is
that right
this is the penetration product this is
what we currently do we currently have
online and we can actually if you want
to see an example
and i allow myself to take one of
do your
like to see that
can you see that
yes
okay so um let's take for example this
episode okay it was from april 6th i
kind of played around with it and what
you have here is our system choosing
between three to five the most engaging
parts of the original video what do you
mean by engaging we do analysis both on
scenes
and visuals and any different types of
audio effects as well as analyze with
using ai the actual spoken words in the
in the video in order to understand what
would be the best clips that can fit
into let's say a one minute tick tock or
a three minute stick talk or one minute
instagram reel so the idea is that you
as a creator can get your original video
chopped up into like you said into a few
clips and then turn from landscape to
portrait so we can publish it directly
to the other uh
to the other platform okay so this is
go ahead yeah
i'm i am human optimization
sean have you ever heard of jelly
smacked i'm shocked or you didn't talk
about them you've heard of jelly smack
right i was waiting for you to raise
their name yeah we heard about the
tickets
actually we love jelly smack we love
what they're doing and we love the fact
that they're doing all the market
education for us
talking to content creators about
content repurposing it
and the fact that you can be successful
equally on all platforms
but genius mac and again we really
admire what they're doing oh come on
we really admire what they're doing but
they've been around for six and a half
years and they have 500 customers and 2
000 employees
manual labor is not really
high-tech new kind of
what we're looking for
using nlp and computer vision we can do
what jlsmeg does
fully automatic on a self-service basis
and fully scalable this is a whole new
level of content management and just to
be clear we're starting with content
repurposing the idea is that we
distribute the content for the content
creator on their behalf on all platforms
so we can take back
the
the analytics that we get from the
platforms and then create a kind of a
cockpit in which the content creator
sees everything that is going on
and can understand what exactly they
need to focus on where is their niche
what is the topic they need to talk more
about and and kind of you know progress
along the lines that every content piece
can become 30 to 50 different types of
common pieces that create more data that
you can then analyze and then
create the whole public loop so
yeah this is the idea well i have a
question really quick but
what's stopping this
to me maybe there's a world where this
kind of becomes like the uh
um
you know buffer buffer.com started just
by like you would schedule like tweets
to go out and then like everyone kind of
offered that same thing and that feature
became somewhat of a commodity
is there a world where this this thing
that you've built becomes a commodity
and you actually have to offer more
stuff like for example i don't actually
know if this is true because i don't
entirely know how they work but it
seemed like jelly smack one of the ways
they make money is they actually don't
charge the creator but they put ads on
the creators videos and they take a cut
and so it's like the technology that
they're offering is just like a feature
and the real value is that they are
giving the creators more revenue by
giving them an ad split and would be the
money maker yeah yeah so is there a
world where this technology you have
really just becomes a commodity and you
got to offer other stuff in order to
keep people on
yeah so the idea is is actually you know
like drop shippers have shopify and
marketers have
spot content creditors will have
munch and the idea behind that is that
currently there is no platform like that
there's a lot of vacuum in this space
and currently this vacuum has been
filled by
hundreds of thousands of freelancers on
fiverr uproar and little to uh to medium
agencies so this is something that
people already consume but either
they're paying premium money for their
services or they're giving up like
between and these are real numbers 30 to
50 percent of the revenue that has been
generated by the agencies
so yeah the idea is that it's going to
be
the central platform for content
creators the central copy they can use
and in terms of the business model if
this is what you're asking so we have
like two options and we're currently
we're still preceded we still you know
playing around experimenting with the
business models we can do both things we
can charge a premium fee for the premium
features and there's there's a lot of
things that we can charge for like you
know creating taking your podcast and
creating twitter threads for the next
month
that we can disable the right time
or we can just use this inventory that
is being created via munch and integrate
brands into it and do brandees and get
money from brands and pay the creators
so we're still not sure which business
model will win right we experiment with
both in the next few months but
yeah it's like um
looks like a huge potential
so so i would not be interested in
investing in this business uh for a
couple reasons but i would say like you
know
the main the main two is like i feel
like it's going to be
based on how difficult it was to get us
interested in the business i think
you're gonna creators are
super busy
uh a thousand opportunities coming at
them at all times and it seems like
you're gonna have to really punch
through the noise in order to be able to
get there and i don't really have
confidence you're gonna be able to do
that that's kind of the first piece uh
second is like any time somebody's using
ai
i'm like oh okay you know
i gotta see it to believe it now what i
will say is
your pitch with the slides was putting
me to sleep but the pitch where you
showed my face i'm like oh wait this is
me great
you know so so i would i would
definitely lead with the demo uh but and
that's not just for us because we create
content a lot of people create content a
lot of investors do but even if it
wasn't us
hey this is a popular podcast blah blah
blah so here it is it's the one hour
thing not everybody's going to watch it
today they pay
you know editors and social media people
thousands of dollars a month to go find
good clips cut them out post them on
tick tock post them on whatever because
they know they're leaving so much growth
on the table if they don't do it
but with munch they'd either be able to
do it themselves or they can hand this
tool to their person so they can make
ten times more clips um you know and and
not have to hire as many people and so
then you're explaining you know the like
your demo was the most impressive part
of your thing where you're like look
long video push a button i get a
properly formatted clip option and i
have you know 10 of these that i can
choose from and we're trying to do this
all automatically right so so i think
that you can
you can make your thing more compelling
um if you kind of like work on how you
explain it versus like it was all
intellectual it was all theory based
whereas you want it to be story based
right so instead of saying you know
content creators fa you know have
complexity when it comes to managing
multiple platforms that's intellectual
uh you want to make it a story which is
like
here's these guys they do this stuff
they record this three-hour thing the
last thing they want to do is this or
hey for your podcast right now we have a
5 000 clip contest running it's like
you're paying five thousand dollars just
for somebody to cut clips of your of
your video into a tick tock what if i
told you that i had a tool that would do
that automatically for you and your
producer could just go do this you know
in 10 minutes after the thing they don't
have to re-watch the video they don't
have to do blank blank blank they have
to resize it they don't have to export
it we've done all of that for you
um and the best part is you know blank
and so i think you can make this a lot
more compelling but as it is right now i
would not be interested in the business
well thanks for the feedback um for that
reasoning i'm out do we do the shark
tank thing i don't know yeah yeah yeah
yeah thanks for the feedback and
regarding customer acquisition actually
this is exactly what we're doing we
we're creating preemptively the videos
for them and then we send them uh via an
email marketing machine that currently
has like a four to five
percent conversion rate and a database
of eight hundred hundred thousand
creators on youtube and we're using
influencer marketing because it turns
out after talking with more than 100
content creators the way that they learn
about new tools and new platforms is by
watching bigger influencers so we're
using influencers in order to get to
more
more customers it's kind of
neat because we just
got to 2 000 users in less than two
months so yeah it's it's kind of
starting to grow
cool sam anything else on your side
the same question um that i that i asked
the other folks
and i don't know why you guys aren't
doing it but paint the picture of like
uh how's this gonna make me wealthier
you know like like i like get down to
like my my primal ins my like my primal
desire here of like i'm giving you money
so how big is this going to get and how
do you sell or go public and i get paid
more than what i gave you uh you know
like paint that picture for me
yeah so
why once we have 5 000 users paying
users we're gonna hit the one million
dollar arr it's an actual error because
it's a recurring revenue once you uh
charge them on the monthly basis
uh and there is a serious uh virality um
and symptom in the area of content
creation it's kind of a plg because once
you create content with munch we have
our logo and some mention to munch on on
the content the idea is that other
creators are watching and getting into
the game so it's gonna
be
a very very quick growth in terms of
sizes current market is 65 billion
dollars it's gonna grow aggressively in
the next few years so you know sky is
the limit uh it's going to be a unicorn
it's going to be a big company and this
is what we're aiming for good i
appreciate you thank you very much
thanks for coming
thank you sir bye i uh sean man like
what i was saying to him about the
the english uh thing dude it is
if you don't speaking if you have an
accent you are at such a legit like just
in terms of logistics and understanding
everything you are at such a
disadvantage for these things it's a
really really hard thing to overcome and
it's i mean it's cool that people uh
overcome it but holy moly i would not
want to be in that position it is tough
right
it is really hard and um
and you know i feel like uh
that's why i think that the deck and the
story i think need to be kind of like
crafted well so that that can be the
kind of like universal language that
you're working with as you as you go
through this i like as an investor and
even just like when i'm never trying to
assess out anything i have to work extra
hard to be like okay this person
well like a lot of times we're investing
sometimes we're investing just on charm
like
all right this person is
charming enough that i feel as though
they're they can convince other
customers to buy or they can convince
employees to join their company uh you
know that's like kind of like that adam
wework guy thing and then there's other
times where i'm like okay but like
what's the idea here is the idea good
and i have to
kind of challenge myself to be like
uh to like look beyond where they
currently are because of maybe like a
lack of
it's just hard to understand man that it
makes a difference and and i have to
like overcome that a little bit
yeah
and i would say some of my best
investments have come from very
charismatic ceos and some of my absolute
worst investments have come from
charismatic ceos it cuts both ways
by the way i can't get into stocks it's
like dead for me um
i had to refresh it as well and everyone
in the chat is saying they had a
refresher too
yeah when i refreshed them let me know
but all right uh either way that's okay
i don't need that open
we want to do another one i think one
more or two more one more
there's allison nickel pass all right
zaza sorry i don't know who's presenting
all right that's me okay guys how are
you
you guys can see my brain
i think they can all right
what's going on uh name is zaza ceo and
co-founder of nickel pass before this i
was the head of international expansion
at huffington post after that i was
groomed to be the cro where i discovered
we were not profitable we were the
largest news site in the world outside
of china and i didn't know before i took
the job that we actually hadn't found a
way to monetize the 200 million people
coming to our websites globally
i'm allison powell ceo and co-founder um
part of this i was actually a banker for
about 10 years
and our way of sharing news and
information on the team was to have my
ea print out an article leave it on the
center conference table and say please
read and that's certainly not a way of
sharing news and information that scales
when you're working on remote teams
distributed teams and asynchronous teams
so nickel pass really solves for all of
that
um and awesome i'll just jump in one of
the things that we've come up with is
the what we call cocktail party pitch uh
when we're at a party people are like
what does nickle pass do and what we say
is you know how you get
uh an article from a friend shared with
you and you get that pop up that says
pay for the full site
well we invented a product where you
never see that again and the way our
business works is we sell it to
enterprises which allows them to get up
to 70 off of retail and we customize the
past based on what each department and
team and user needs to be successful
so here's the nickel pass
i'm in front of a business insider
paywall
i click the button oops i don't think
there we go
okay there we go
through the paywall
so
i hit a paywall
i go to my nickel pass which is a chrome
extension click on business insider and
that's it i never see a paywall again
so
it looks like we're having a little bit
of who's sharing what but you guys saw
the product um a couple of things about
the business so because of our
background the chairman of the company
is the former head of strategy at cnn uh
we've been able to collect a network of
over 200 publications including the la
times uh crunchbase pro time magazine
and we always like to point out that
beer business daily is on here for a
reason if i'm an enterprise we work with
anheuser-busch they don't need just the
new york times they also need uh beer
business daily which
tells them about how the craft beer
market is doing in the pacific northwest
uh in terms of the business we booked
over a million in revenue so that's a
million of hard revenue and 1.2 of
bookings some of uh the companies we
work with include anheuser-busch as
mentioned visa and also publicist and
havas which are respectively the number
one and number two marketing and pr
agencies in the world in terms of why
people come to us if you wanted to get
these subscriptions yourself
be our guest it costs you over a
thousand dollars a year just for five
different sites obviously that's not
going to scale if you're an enterprise
and some of the other problems in the
space and the reason we've been able to
get so much traction 18 months uh number
two there is no tech enabled way to buy
group subscriptions so if you wanted 10
licenses from the new york times today
you're essentially filling out a form
and then number three
uh
now three out of every four news sites
require a subscription or have a paywall
when we started the business
now a little over three years ago that
number was at uh 30 so about one in
three sites
so we'll stop there this is awesome
this is awesome
so we can just recap uh because i think
some people are having trouble in the
stocks platforms they might have missed
the beginning of the pitch but basically
what you did is
i work at a company i go try to click
some article to read some important news
story that some my coworker sent me
i hit with a pay wall oh hey man what
did it say i don't have a business
insider subscription
and
our company which is let's pretend we
work at google
oh google uses nickel pass so i can just
use the chrome extension and bypass the
paywall because google has paid for a
multi-seat
uh license to business insider so
business insider is getting this huge
bulk subscription buy and they'll give
it at a discount google wants its
employees to be able to read news and
employees don't have to pay for it out
of pocket that's what happens that's
that's that's exactly i'll add some
other things publishers right now
convert less than one percent of the
people that come to their website to pay
for the full subscription so it's a
win-win for everyone where they they're
basically getting all these people that
they would be monetizing at cents on the
dollar per year from advertising
but do you if if google buys 20 seats
do they only get business insider or do
they also get all the other publications
you had listed there and if they if the
second one how do you figure out who
which publisher gets paid what money
right yeah so we have over 200
publishers in our network we add more
every day
we create bespoke packages so how we
have an initial package that's you pick
six out of ten publications it includes
business insider and many others and
that's 23.95 a user a month for that
package after that we'll upsell from
there and we work with customers to
design custom packages based on the
industry you're in and the role you're
in in your industry so if you work at a
big bank and you're in marketing in pr
you're going to need a very different
set of publications than someone who's
at the coms team at google but you will
be able to work with you to customize
that and a lot of that you're now able
to do on your own on our administrative
panel but then how does uh
if let's just use round numbers let's
say it's thirty dollars a month
does this and you have two publications
does business insider get ten dollars
new york times get ten dollars and you
guys get ten dollars so what we do is we
work with the publishers to either take
rate cards they have or create ones from
scratch and so that way in the custom
package the publishers always made holes
so in your example it all depends on the
number of seats that google signs up
with so if they sign up with uh 10
people or a thousand people the price
may go from 10 a month which is a 20
discount off of retail to two dollars a
month which is you know much more off of
retail and then we bundle that and then
charge an administrative fee on top of
that and that's the bespoke package
what's the fee percent
uh so right now gross margin is anywhere
from 44 to 55
um and that's a combination of not only
the seat fee but we integrate with uh
octa microsoft active directory so it's
really single sign-on for news public
defense and we basically handle all of
the admin uh for both the enterprise and
the publisher
that's amazing so uh let's talk let's
talk about the traction okay so you
showed a bunch of publications that you
guys have gotten to agree with this how
many companies are paying for this i
don't know if i i missed that part or uh
it wasn't in there
yeah yep so
we have over 125 companies who we
currently work with and we're we're
adding more every day both uh smaller
companies as well as large enterprises
uh and what does that mean for revenue
for you guys
yep so we're at 1.2 million um arr and
we're on track to be 3 million by the
end of the year
and raising at a 15 million valuation
and that's 3 million as in net revenue
and you get or is that three million as
in you there's three million there's
three million for the bundle and you
take 45 to 50 of it that's right
the second one
correct
so more like 1.5 million is that
in real net revenue is that right
in net revenue yes 1.5 and um
okay great and so and how do you how do
you onboard customers so what do you do
to go get the next
25 50 customers what what happens
well i think one of the things that
we're really excited about is the 120
companies we have they have over 400 000
employees so what we found is that it's
much easier to upsell within an
organization once you land them so what
we're seeing is that our gross
trajectory if we go from the one percent
to three percent that's how you get to
the three and that's why only focusing
on two segments right now marketing and
pr and then consumer finance that
doesn't count telco doesn't count on
some of the tech companies you mentioned
it doesn't count international which is
actually my background post
gotcha so you're just going to expand
within the companies you're already in
to get to to get to three million okay
but how do you get more customers uh
from here what is the strategy is it
outbound is it inbound is it yeah
program what do you do yep
yeah it's we primarily have a cold
outbound marketing strategy um so we do
a lot of lead gen
and then we do some organic search and
organic social and now this is a cost to
companies at a time when a lot of
companies are cutting costs right so
today
they're just not paying for this and
employees are just not getting the
benefit or they're paying you know
employees pay out of pocket yeah um if i
do this and i have you know one percent
of my employees doing this all of a
sudden i've added a
i don't know what your what your average
volume is but let's say 10 grand 10 10
grand uh
a year what is the average cost of
company
so that that's grown when we first
started it was roughly the seven to ten
grand a year now what we're seeing is uh
50k um and that um having opportunity to
grow and here's the thing you know
people see it from two lenses so there's
the cost savings and they look at our
class and they're like well it's better
than everyone buying it at retail and
expensing it back to the company so
that's one thing the second thing is in
a time like this
if you miss a critical piece of news in
your industry the opportunity cost for
that is much higher and so you're going
to feel some type of way for not paying
the 50 bucks per person per seat because
you're like oh i was trying to like
basically refine the cost we like to say
what we're going after is the budget
people used to use on soda machines
because this is one of those
oh oh i think we've
lost those out there um but yes this is
an expense that people actually already
have they just don't realize that
frequently it's being put on personal
cards and then expensed back to the
company so the other thing that we're
doing is actually giving finance and
procurement a single line on them so
they really understand how much they're
spending on news and information and
data which for the 40 professional the
40 million thousand the 40 million
professional services workers in the us
is extremely important to know
okay great uh i also feel like there's
probably some strategy where you go to
anheuser-busch and then has a you know
once they have their one percent of
people on you go to every other
beer company out there and you say hey
anheuser-busch does this so that their
employees can read beer journal daily
and this and that uh you know would you
guys be interested there's a i think
within industries you could sort of play
play off each other a little bit
exactly and we we've seen that um social
proof model work extremely well with
marketing and pr firms and with
financial services firms allison how big
is this going to get you know what are
you what you're going to get to 100
million in recurring revenue what's
going to happen
yeah without a doubt so we are we see
ourselves as really the next uh version
of cable um and how we access news
content and information um digitally is
going to change drastically from how it
it works today um and nickel pass is
going to be the single stop solution for
that what um how many employees
let me ask that same question a little
bit differently uh because sam likes to
hear kind of how big is the dream i like
to hear a little bit differently which
is
what would i need to believe
for this to be at 100 million in revenue
meaning how many companies how many
people what how do you work your way to
100 million in revenue
yeah so our goal has always been to get
everyone access to quality news and
information and by everyone we don't
just mean professional services workers
we also mean individuals and there's a
certain price point that individuals can
pay for access to quality news and
information so we're exploring what that
is but i think it's extremely important
to note that over the past five years
we've understood
the general public so actually you're
gonna be the math so like this many
companies paying this much a month is
100 million in revenue and then
i need to know is that a believable
number of companies that's like you know
out of the total universe so how many
companies would you need to be paying
you
for you to be at that point
yeah so we'd need to be at about um ten
thousand companies based on on our
initial math so 10 000 companies and um
you think that those will
you know right now you're at whatever 25
you think about the end of the year you
can get to
maybe 40 or 50 something like that uh oh
no we're at 150 right sorry you're 150
great yeah we're
you know well beyond the that initial
group and what are you guys gonna have
to do to go from 150 to 10 000 companies
what will actually need to happen
yeah so it's it's two-pronged it's that
we have to increase our penetration rate
on the existing companies from one
percent to three percent um and that
number is even achievable up to the five
or ten percent range and then we have to
increase our penetration in this in the
specific sectors from currently 0.01
to uh closer to one percent in each
sector so financial services marketing
and pr
um and then universities and
associations as well
gotcha okay all right thanks i think uh
we might be able to add one more did you
have you raised any money so far and
from who yep
yeah so we've raised about 5 million so
far
that's our last round was led by river
park ventures so the
seamless
food ordering company co-founders
because they took the same b to b model
to get to a b to c model um and we have
a number of uh other institutionals as
well 68 capital rate ventures damn you
raised 5 million at a 15 million
valuation
no smaller valuation in the past so this
new this new round is uh 15 million free
money oh so you gave up a lot of the
company yeah what are you how are you
gonna stay motivated you gotta
yeah so i understood so we are um
reworking the cap table as we speak
because basically we pivoted the company
from a blockchain micropayments and so
that's total over the pivot
that's uh
by the way respect for pivoting away
from blockchain that sort of shows me
that you're a
clear and independent thinker that
didn't just like oh here's the trend we
are a web three company for micro
payments you can create a lightning and
it's like what do people do our
customers actually want and in this case
you found out what they actually wanted
which was not
not that not something else yeah
customers hated it publishers loved it
but it wasn't selling to um to anyone as
recurring revenue right and we could
have raised it a much higher valuation
but we chose to fit it i think i think
your product is awesome it sounds like
your cap table is
shitty to be blunt i would love i would
love to hear a little bit more about how
i don't want to hear about it now but
like how you're going to get out of that
situation i think it's it's hopefully
it's fixable because this product sounds
pretty sick um and we gotta ask people
are asking why what is nickel pass what
is this name why are you named after
nickelback
uh news used to cost a nickel so that's
okay why
right great
and now it costs 23 per person per month
congratulations this is sick this is
sick i think your pitch was awesome i
said what i thought about the cap table
the product's badass um one little thing
between your act together though between
you and your co-founder you guys should
figure out who's going to answer
questions and which types of questions
so you automatically know
when to defer because it's a little bit
of a signal when you're doing a pitch
and like both are kind of like me and
sam does we talk over each other a
little bit it's okay in a podcast or
realm but as a company you kind of need
to know
okay technical questions this person's
going to answer uh growth questions this
person's going to answer
uh or this one person's going to answer
everything and then they're going to say
you know allison why don't you talk
about that you're you're you know she
knows it's better than anybody and so
you'll be able to kind of defer a little
bit better um in that sense but good
really good job overall with the pitch
that's my only kind of pitch feedback
for you
great thank you guys
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
sick sick company god damn man that cat
table really [__] things up for her
yeah uh yeah i think that's okay though
i think it's recoverable or um
you know like some people like you know
how are you gonna stay motivated some
people are motivated
you know the number whether the number
whether they're on 50 or 35 percent they
they sort of feel the same about it it's
their baby and also they can be
motivated by the regret that's giving
away so much of the company that's crazy
to me i i am
i am friends with this guy who sold his
company for a billion dollars
and he 990 million and he walked away
with three million dollars because he
had
it was five of them either or four of
them so it was four or five of them and
they raised all this money and he walked
away with three million dollars on a
billion dollar value
sale and that crazy i i can't
i don't understand how you get motivated
when you're not gonna get paid
yeah well some people uh
some people motivated by the mission
some people don't do the math some
people are like well [__] i'm stuck now
i made that mistake and now uh i guess i
gotta live with that i gotta i guess i
gotta eat that one um and by the way
shout out to her uh we don't do public
math but we sure as hell make founders
do public math when they pitch us uh
because you know you gotta be able to
answer that question in fact i don't
even care what the like some people
think that when i ask that question how
do you get to 100 million or how do you
get to 10 million arr
i'm like
judging whether uh i'm judging whether
that thing sounds feasible or not and
that's part of it but the bigger part of
it is does this seem like the first time
they've done this math or have they done
this before because if they haven't done
it if they haven't done it before i'm
like oh this person's not actually
thinking of plotting how to like take
over and like how to build this into
something big they're just kind of like
buried their head in product and like
they may not have if they haven't
thought of it up till now they're
probably not going to be thinking about
that in the future in this case i
thought that she
she had an answer i haven't done the
math to go check if that answer was like
you know [__] or real but she had at
least thought about we need 10 000
companies at our current you know
pricing and scale to be at that um you
know that revenue mark well and i and
and i think people like think it's a
trick question towards like how does
this get big or um how are you going to
exit and they'll say like this [__]
of like well we're not thinking about an
exit it's like dude come on just like
this like talk real like a good answer
is like well the worst case scenario is
i think we'll get to 5 million in this
many years and someone's going to buy us
for 50 million and you'll get a two or
three x return i think that's like a
likely worst case scenario best case
scenario i actually think we have a
clear path to 75 million and we're going
to figure out as we go and i think these
possible doors might open up and then we
could either go public which i would
love to go public or we could sell for
this much money or we just own the
company forever and we grow into this
i think that answer works on you because
you invest your own money for most
venture capitalists they're investing in
other people's money they don't care
about the two to three x uh i know but
i'm trying to downside protection it's
like to them it's either a zero or it's
huge and so you're better off focusing
most of the energy on the
uh how this ends up huge and you might
just say you might say things like um so
you don't have to say oh man i can't
wait to go sell this for a billion
dollars but i think you could say like
like we had a buddy ramon who was
telling us about this he's like look
right now i have you know i don't know
what it was like a hundred thousand
um you know like pet owners
um who have bought from me and i know
their name their address their dog's
name their dog's breed their dog's age i
know everything about them he goes and
he's named like the big you know chewy
doesn't know any of that because they
sell
on store shelves but i have the largest
databases i think that asset's going to
be worth a lot of money to one of these
companies and i think that you know
that's beyond just the sales that we're
already doing and so you can kind of
say your downside protection that we're
building a valuable app that's kind of
what i mean i'm just saying that like
just it's okay to show weakness and it's
okay to show uncertainty but at the same
time you also want to have like a yeah
but i think this could happen and here's
how what the flight booking guy said is
also perfect which is you don't have to
say this is going to be a billion dollar
company you're just going to autopilot
like a you know venture capital robot
like you know what he could say is
basically
um
you know he's like he's like you know i
don't know what the i don't know where
the ceiling of this is because nobody's
ever done this before but there's a
clear path to 75 million and we're going
to get there then we're going to look up
and figure out what's next
and i think that's a totally honest but
also exciting version of that answer
which is to say like look we don't know
how high this thing can fly
but i know there's a clear path to this
i'm just laser focused 50 million an
hour before i go to bed i kiss my
daughter goodnight and i say 50 million
in arr and when i wake up and i'm
brushing my teeth i say 50 million are
because i know that that's what's in
front of us and like i can't sleep
because it's so obvious that there's a
step-by-step path to go get there so you
can say some [__] like that and
people get like people start to believe
that you believe that that's your
certainty that there's a clear path to
that makes them certain there's a clear
path to it
badass let's do the last one
up colton take it away
hi
i'm colton woodard founder of little
ducky's pool company
i'm a pool industry expert with a knack
for sourcing companies that may not know
they want to sell and creating
acquisition plan
started out with my own pool maintenance
business from zero clients now i make
about eighteen thousand monthly
recurring revenue
all in under three years my
father-in-law owns a large pool
resurfacing company in orlando florida
and found our first private acquisition
deal from a friend who was feeling like
he was ready to retire
instead of just letting his business
dissolve we negotiated a purchase at
about a multiple
of you know four months of the monthly
gross revenue
currently we've secured two upcoming
purchase contracts in the south florida
pool construction sector
with another in negotiation for quarter
four
we are projecting 10.3 million and gross
for our 2023 sales with a yearly
increase of 13 as we streamline the
processes and add in modern tech
or we're looking to build a portfolio of
pool construction companies in south
florida and gain a majority of the
market share and then add in pool
cleaning and maintenance on these
accounts for additional monthly
reoccurring revenue
ideally we like to secure locations in
all of south florida within the next
five years
with four owner operators in place who
know the industry know the business how
to utilize specific contractors we're
looking to take over the industry and
build an empire
like real estate now is the hottest time
to invest in south florida pool
construction
sick so uh
let me bait is this basically like a pe
play where you're buying
uh baby boomers
businesses who put pools in people's
backyards
in a simple and a simple explanation
kind of yeah i mean it's it's a little
harder than that because you know sell
40 you dig 54 inches you hit water so if
you don't know what you're doing you
could really muck it up
but yeah so we know the industry we know
the pool we know pool construction so we
can find people that are ready to retire
and instead of letting their business
just go to the wind and the other guys
pick it all up
we can utilize different contractors
that specialize in you know form and
steel excavation take his company and he
sub contracts out to the plumbing guys
and the tile guys the screen enclosure
guys and he's spending so much money on
paying subcontractors whatever they need
to charge because he's got to hire
because he can't do it himself
so we buy these individual companies
that can complement each other bring
everything in-house and we can get our
permits done faster
reduce our wait times and increase
profits and turn over more projects year
over year so that's why we're looking at
thirteen percent increase on our product
so just exp
uh multiple choice answer your company
does what do you a sell software b buy
existing pool companies uh c
uh invest in cool cos or d other which
one of those four things do you do
b we we buy pool companies mergers and
acquisitions yeah so you you're rolling
up pool companies and you're rolling
them up and you are a good you are not
buying them for less or anything like
that you buy them at some fair value but
you are better operating because you do
what a
you uh have different expertise in house
b you have better software
c you uh have economies of scale what is
the advantage you have
uh a and b
so we we know the business we do it well
and we implement modern technology so
3d modeling designs for the pools so we
can email it to customer we don't got to
go to their house with a pen and paper
and show them how it's done
so we can just email it over and then
also since covet hit permitting has been
horrible slowed down a lot now we can do
digital permitting where we can be on
video chat with the
with the county that we're working with
and they could be right on the phone we
could show them step by step and get the
phases approved without having to wait
for time on their schedule for them to
come to the site so the result is you
guys build pools for
faster and cheaper how much faster and
how much cheaper
we build them faster we don't build them
cheaper
it depends on the county you know each
county is going to be a little bit
different but if you don't have to wait
on the subcontractors to get you on
their schedule or not show up and and
reschedule on you
it's it's going to be at least 20
percent faster
okay great and you up till now you've
bought how many pool companies
so right now we've signed we have our
own we own two but we bought uh we have
two purchase contracts signed an
agreement and we have one in negotiation
that we're looking to get another round
of funding for
and then explain when you buy a business
like this uh you know it has this much
in ebitda typically it's been in
business for 10 years or whatever and
you're buying it at some multiple
um and you're financing it how
well the first two we sold our houses
okay
what do you do for the next two
we're looking to raise capital and then
we're also going to make a plan using
the um signed contracts usually you're
two years out
you know two years booked out with these
with these contracts for the pool
companies that we're buying so we're not
only we're buying the company we're
buying the crew we're having the owner
stay on for two years as a consultant
while we put a project manager in place
for him to train and then we're getting
all of those contracts um and they get
paid in phases so we use some of the
working capital to put aside into
another fund to use to purchase more
businesses as we
as we roll out
all the locations we need between like i
said form steel excavation shot crete
tile marsite plaster guys we're we're
going to buy all the specialty
contractors and roll them all into one
company so
sean and i's one of our best investments
ever we i think we both invested at the
same time into a business johnny is
still there yeah
we both invest we invested into this
business uh that started by our friend
sieva called endure ventures and his
whole premise was to buy businesses that
baby boomers want to retire and their
kids don't want to take it over
basically that's exactly what's going on
and sam zell sam sells the guy who
basically created the reit he um owned
schwinn bikes he owned the tribune he
owned a bunch of stuff
rich guy he owned waste management i
think
um anyway he said recently in a podcast
that he is making more money off of
buying businesses from baby boomers who
don't want to pass their companies onto
the kids than he has ever made in real
estate
and so that's just for the proof that
this is actually quite interesting and i
think sieva actually bought a pool
business didn't he
shawn yeah yeah dolphin pools it's in
arizona yeah and they're killing it i
would argue that that's probably the
path you should go and for these pitches
you should entirely pitch it that way um
another way that you could maybe pitch
is the guy who started i was going to
bring this up on the podcast sean but
the guy who started wework uh we uh
upwork have you heard of upwork it's
like the outsourcing tech company he um
started this new company called
i actually don't know how he's air
guillon
e-r-g-e-o-n and it's a fence contractor
and installation and repair business and
he just raised like 40 million dollars
for it and he bootstrapped it to like
400 employees do you see this sean no
i've never seen that that's crazy dude
it just got relaunched like or just got
released like two days ago on techcrunch
he was like they were like i uh we
wanted to keep this in the dl but
basically we bootstrapped this into a
monster business and we just raised
financing for it and at a huge valuation
because getting someone to build a fence
it's a pain in the ass well we just went
and just like you so what they did is
they used a little bit of technology and
they made the process easier and better
what sieve is doing is he's just saying
no one wants these businesses we're
going to buy them for cheap and we're
just going to install a manager and let
it run so anyway i think if i was you i
would go one of those two routes and i
would go all in on one of those two
routes i imagine seeing that your
website i went to it it looks like it's
built on wix technology's not gonna be
where you're gonna play it's gonna be
the pe route but the problem is is you
don't actually seem entirely bought in
on that route so that's like my fairly
critical feedback do you think i hit the
nail on the head there sean
if i can go ahead called if i can
interject i i think that
yeah that's that's pretty accurate it's
a little it's a little bit more
difficult you know these guys they are
retiring but they also it's very
difficult to get into this industry you
have to have four years of experience
and then go in front of a board the dppr
to even get approved to have the license
to do it
so it's not like
millennials or gen z can just hey i'm
going to start a pool construction
company today
you're going to have to go work for
somebody for four years to get that
experience to even do it so it's it's
really not super turnkey so there's not
a lot of competition for the pe
um to go out and scoop them up you know
we're poised and ready to strike
okay
yeah um
i would say i'm just gonna give you some
pitch feedback because i think your
pitch was uh confusing
and therefore
hard to
raise money which is what we're here to
do right so
um
number one uh like use a you you had a
slide up there that had a bunch of text
but then you talked a bunch and you
weren't talking exactly you weren't just
saying the points on the slide you were
telling a story which was good it's good
to tell a story but if you're gonna tell
story to put like a picture on the
screen um so it's like you know this is
uh you know this is my pool company
we've been doing this this business
spits off this much cash and we're you
know we're not alone there's
400 of these just in the florida area
where i you know where i'm from and i've
bought two more of these and these are
great businesses to buy in fact i sold
my house to buy these because they're
such a better investment than my home
and you know this first one we bought we
bought it for this much it's already
paid itself off in two years and blah
blah the second one blah blah blah same
thing and for each one of these we have
a playbook of how to buy it grow it and
like improve it from where it was we
improved each of these businesses by
over 25 percent within the first year
okay great so we're going to keep doing
this we have a plan that is working um
you know but i don't have any more
houses to sell so it's time for me to go
raise some money
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna raise
five million dollars i'm gonna go buy
20 million dollars worth of uh of pool
pool companies and we're gonna start
rolling these up you've probably seen
these roll ups get pretty big this roll
up in the dental space got this big this
roll up and the pool space got this big
in a different state you know sam zell
the guy who invented the reit is doing
doing these roll up the guy who started
upwork is now doing this with fencing
companies
um this is a strategy that works now the
problem is most people don't have what i
have they don't have 15 years of pool
construction experience so even if they
wanted to do this they wouldn't really
know where to start they wouldn't know
the nuances of permitting and i could
say a bunch of words you're not going to
understand but that those are kind of 15
years of hard work lessons and so today
i'm coming here to i'm going to raise
this i'm going to build a billion dollar
pool roll up company and like you got to
say that category of your company the
size the price all of that i think would
be
like i don't know if you heard that in
the chat i know stocks having some
problems right now but if you heard that
the chat
go
one to ten uh where was my pitch on a
scale of one to ten of clear and
compelling
um
because that's where you need to get
this too because i think you actually
have a really good idea
uh i don't i don't think we need to
we need a smart investor like you sean
because man you you said it perfectly
yeah but he didn't want to do the work
he wants you to do the work yeah i want
you to be the one who says like you know
i i want to invest in people who figure
these things out if i'm if you need me
for help honestly it's uh usually a bad
sign for my investment uh like i want to
be helping a rocket that's already going
and not like pushing something that's at
a standstill and so um well you know you
know the investment industry and you
know the roll-ups and you know the
comparables i'm i'm out here doing the
doing the hard work managing crews fair
enough fair enough uh and so i think
take that and basically say okay
the problem was i wasn't clear on what
type of investment vehicle this is this
is a roll-up
second um i gotta weave my story just a
bit of my story which is that i'm i've
got tons of experience doing this i've
already started my roll up this is not
just a idea that's pie in the sky i
already got the first two under my belt
i did those myself bootstrapped and
they're working and now i just got to
tell you how we're going to go from 2 to
20 doing this and that when we have 20
it's going to be worth this much because
i can just do some math say 20 times
each one is worth 10 million dollars now
i got a 200 million roll up uh if we if
we could pull this off right
beautifully said the other thing is you
didn't say anything about debt are you
taking on debt for doing this you said
you're kind of raising money to buy the
next ones why aren't you using debt
we haven't taken any loans we thought
about it we thought about doing sba but
um
i mean it just made more sense to sell
our finance so what we we actually did
was we negotiated like a 10 down with
seller financing over five years of the
balloon payment and the it's so cheap we
can just dude why didn't you say that
that's a that's a great point i'm buying
these for 10 percent down i'm like
giving you interest i'm giving away my
secrets over the internet to thousands
of people now millions of your podcast
listeners so here you go there's no
one's gonna you you it's not a secret
see selling friday's secret
uh it's in fact you kind of made it
sound like you don't know what debt is
because you didn't say anything but uh
now we've revealed the truth okay great
honestly again i think you actually have
a very good business idea um presented
slightly differently that'd be you know
i think it could be
very investment worthy especially right
now you know you see stocks going down
you see crypto going down these private
companies are raising huge valuations
with like you know software and a dream
whereas you're like actually i buy
successful profitable companies
and i'm just a better operator than the
mom and pop and i'm gonna aggregate
these because like i just have a
playbook that i can just keep rolling
out and by the way i buy these for 10
down so that means you know
uh you know my cash on cash return after
you know 15 months looks like this and
so you you have a very very strong pitch
um
and you just got to like you know put it
all together
yeah after 30 years of doing something
they're going to be real tired you know
they don't want to they don't want to
push the needle they don't want to make
it bigger they have a paycheck coming in
salary they're taken care of so right
there was a guy so right now for the
listeners colton he's sitting in front
of a bookshelf that's empty and someone
just says uh
peter thiel's zero to one is not on his
bookshelf and for that reason i'm out
this is where all of my trophies are
going to go for uh for all the wins
we're about to have
oh lean startups not on his bookshelf
for that reason i'm out
yeah dude
you seem to be spending too much time
actually building your business i need
somebody who's way more into reading
about business
yeah you don't seem like you do yoga i'm
out you're on a gamer chair you're not
like
on a treadmill desk i'm out you eat
carbs i'm out
yeah that's hilarious uh thanks dude
thanks for coming on thank you so much
um
all right uh i asked i don't know if
ollie's gonna pop up the guy starts
talks but that was that was fun um
some i think some people need some work
on their pitch not as much work on their
business but work on just
like saying what the [__] they do so
let's go most interested to least
interested
uh let's rank the companies based on on
that i'll kind of remind you what they
were so there was 5x that was the first
business that pitched which was doing
something that we could barely
understand but had a million dollars of
ar commitments um you know for his kind
of like marketing stack that he was or
you know there's like vendor stack that
he was putting in a box
then we had i think fly together which
wasn't their name it was like bukhari or
something like that group booking on
travel
uh third one we had was uh orem who was
doing munch i think
uh which was taking creators content and
letting you chop it up into bits and
letting them making it easy for them to
repost using ai and some software
then we had uh the last guy was duckies
and before that we had nickel pass did i
miss anyone
yeah
all right i did miss someone or no no i
don't think you missed someone i think
my ranking from most to least from the
ones i would want to invest into the
least i would actually put nickel and
fly together
maybe nickel first but the fly together
bakari i would put that they would trade
for one or two in the middle would be 5x
and then uh tied for the bottom ones
would be uh the jelly smack competitor
and duckies
okay all right i like it mine would be
fly together number one
i thought that uh he seemed great and
the business seemed you know pretty
straightforward and had momentum
and you know i need to go look at the
competition like is it really as
backwards and he's kind of the only real
one doing this as it made it sound but i
i like the sound of that one um i
actually think that duckies is probably
the second or first best investment uh
but i'm not sure i would want to invest
in colton just because you know he
seemed like i think i'd want to hang out
with him but i'm not sure i'd want to
invest in him because i feel like i'd
just be frustrated because he speaks a
different language than me he speaks
like
digging holes in the ground and building
pools and like i speak like frameworks
it's like you know hey colton i like you
just change the way you look for me
please yeah just like just talked
entirely different for me
if i invested in it i'd be like look
we're allowed to hang out but we'll
never be allowed to talk about the
business and like in 20 years just mail
me a giant check and just in between i
need to pretend it's gone uh so that's
that'll be mistaken and by the way i'm
colton i'm messing with you
[Laughter]
um also i love the name of that little
duckies that's a great cool name uh i do
nickel pass three and then the other two
i probably wouldn't invest in so those
are kind of like four and five um all
right ali you're here the crowd is
beating you up because stonks was
crashing ollie just is it because we're
too popular are we just too popular is
that what happened or or is it somehow
something else and this is ali moyes the
founder of stocks yes
thanks for having me guys great great
show loved the real talk honestly i
think it's it's the best real talk we've
had on songs
uh and and uh you know the comments show
it um yeah so you guys crashed once you
you
this this is one of our biggest events
um uh and we were also in the middle of
like a code migration so there were more
issues at this event than the last like
50 events put together
so the stream crashed a few times but a
page refresh did fix it
but it it will be a lot more stable
going forward so thank you for hanging
in there and i could attest that so
people don't know this me and you we
used to compete at our previous startups
so you built stream labs we were
building bebo we're both trying to build
tools for live streamers on twitch and
so i've seen you execute from uh you
know first of all that we became friends
kind of towards the end um but like
you're good and uh when you decide to do
something uh you guys pull you know you
guys are scrappy and you pull it off
and uh actually when we were competing
against each other i had asked i told uh
michael burch who was the founder of the
original bebo and he was our investor i
said yeah there's this company
streamlabs out there he's like who's
behind it and i told him your name he
goes
i know these guys he used to have some
company called peanut something
and he's like oh these guys these guys
are like you know they always just find
like the thing that people want and he
was basically described just very
scrappy entrepreneurs who will just like
kind of like
you'll never die
and you'll like kind of just keep
iterating until you find this like hook
that people want and then you'll like go
for it uh we'll go for it with like full
force is that an accurate thank you
thank you you are your duke and sean
matt have a lot of respect for what you
did as well amazing products
uh and you guys kick your ass for what
it's worth i feel like the uh in the end
we were competing with you guys but it
really you guys kicked our ass
no no it's uh it's great i mean um i
have a lot of respect for for for you
and uh you know what you what you've
done in uh birch as well um
but uh amazing amazing event today guys
it's just our our team has been loving
it the chat's been loving it i think sam
asked
um everyone should we do it again seems
like
seems like the chat is uh really into it
yes
dude so on the podcast yesterday we
talked about this company called stake
and they're like an online crypto
gambling website and they basically give
drake a certain amount of money like 10
million dollars a month in order to get
20 million dollars a month in order to
gamble on the website and he tweets
about it and people come and watch him
gamble and they give him free house
money to play with in order to attract
more users so we'll take two this is a
gambling this is a gambling website
it's called steak.com yeah it's awesome
so it's really effective for that
company
is this a hint do we need to set up like
house money for you guys like exactly
okay yes exactly i think that you give
us each like 10 or 20 grand to invest in
different startups and by the way we
will invest random ass influencers and
also so we'll go get you know we'll get
jake paul in here we'll just go get a
bunch of like other famous people to be
our friend of the house and just give us
a house budget to go invest in startups
you know this is this is actually not uh
a half joke half idea but this is
actually not a terrible idea this is oh
so we have a
look
don't don't don't don't assume smiling
means a joke i am not joking i'm being
dead serious we should do this
so uh
so the way we could do it is we we we
have a small farm
it's called the best of stocks fund
and we do write checks into interesting
startups particularly high traction or
great co-investors
similar to what you guys look for so
what we could do is for your next event
we could each give you
um one one check so you pick your one
favorite startup out of the five or so
that pitch at your next event and and
we'll write that
yeah but i want uh we we want stakes in
it bro
ah okay so that's that's a little more
work
i have to figure it out
that's all right let me let me get back
to you
maybe maybe we could give you some carry
on that or yeah that would be for
something okay that'd be cool
all right so um also people need to know
that ali moyes is not the same as boys
ali the the other guest on our podcast
all the time did i call him
i don't know you said it right but
people in the chat are like wait is this
the deodorant guy it's like no there's
there's moyes on league that's the other
guy there's ollie moyes that's the
stonks guy so i'm not the investing guy
not the deodorant guy you to be sick of
that i have to assume
uh you know it's fine it's it's more
followers for both of us people we we
confuse all our followers it's great
that's amazing okay and also we've been
doing this bookshelf meme this whole
time get us a book off the shelf there
something that has helped you've sold a
company for over 100 million dollars i
believe uh
and uh so so you read books and you've
had success go give us a book off that
shelf there that you will recommend to
the crowd something that you think has
helped you
um i think
bring it over go grab the book okay okay
dude uh he's got a nice house does he
live in san francisco now it's actually
my test to see if he's wearing only
underwear uh on a lot on on zooms and no
he he passed he's wearing wearing shorts
if you ask me to get up right now
you might be uh you know this this
stream might might be rated you know
pg-13 at least
are you wearing only underwear right now
i'm wearing my jammies which are which
are more than underwear
okay
so this this is what i'm reading right
now i have the same one dance read
um
huge fan
so it looks like uh i've actually bought
this as well so it's a
compilation of uh night from 1964 i
think up until 2010 or i forget the year
of every single one of warren buffett's
annual letters and what you'll notice i
actually analyzed this his words per
sentence actually gets shorter and
shorter each year and i would argue
that's because he's becoming a better
writer and what's really interesting
about that book is he explains like
really complicated topics like geico car
insurance and incredibly easy to
understand ways so i think that's a good
book to read
that's cool connor in the chat goes you
picked the heaviest book he has power
move i agree
absolute alpha move of you just now to
go pull a a you know 36 pound book off
the shop i i appreciate that
all right well
uh ollie thanks for help tell your boy
john hancock and the rest of the team
thanks for making this happen this was
awesome uh sean uh i think i guess we'll
do this again this was it was pretty
good i think we had a little kinks
workout but it's pretty good
yeah let us know tweet at us um if
you're if you're here live or if you
listen to the pod tweet it is if you
want us to do more of these or or uh you
know if this should be a one-time thing
[Music]
you